Не так давно вона інакше уявляла своє майбутнє.
Журналістка і телеведуча Беата Тадла готується до ефіру
на приватному телеканалі NОwa TV.
До приходу до влади націонал-консервативного уряду
Беата була однією з найбільш популярних телеведучих
на державному Польському телебаченні. Але все змінилося.
Я прийшла на роботу, а за моїм комп'ютером в редакції сиділа інша людина,
яка мала вести програму замість мене.
Директор сказав, що він мене любить і цінує,
але я, на жаль, не вписуюся в нову концепцію каналу.
Новою концепцією стала відданість урядовому курсу.
Звільнення Беати та ще понад двохсот її колег  спричинило протести.
Їх же замінили на слухняних журналістів.
Уряд назвав це "маленьким законом про ЗМІ".
Мене дуже зворушило, коли люди вийшли на протести проти звільнень.
Було очевидно, що вони виступають
проти пропаганди і розуміють,
що польське телебачення стає рупором уряду.
Генеральним директором Польського громадського телебачення
призначили зручну для уряду людину.
Програму суттєво змінили.
Тепер курс телеканалу збігається з лінією уряду.
Тут правляча партія виконує обіцянки -
якщо йдеться про будівництво доріг.
І тут регулярно лунає критика на адресу Євросоюзу та Німеччини.
Ян Ординскі сам колись був журналістом польського державного каналу.
А зараз - керує однією з журналістських спілок
і з тривогою спостерігає за останніми подіями.
Мета цих змін - абсолютний контроль над ЗМІ.
Загальна редакційна політика, яка буде влаштовувати уряд.
Є й інша журналістська спілка,
близька до уряду. Яка вітає зміни на телебаченні.
Суспільно-правові засоби масової інформації
дійсно радикально змінилися.
Але таким чином у Польщі дотримується певний баланс у ЗМІ.
Приватні ЗМІ пов'язані з опозицією,
а громадські - з урядовим табором.
Приватний канал TVN.
Тут критично ставляться до політики уряду.
І відчувають наслідки своєї критики.
Каналу потрібно доплатити податки.
Крім того, йому загрожує і великий штраф  за нібито
протиправне висвітлення однієї демонстрації.
Канал належить американській групі інвесторів і завдяки тиску з боку США
скаргу - цього разу - відкликали.
З труднощами стикнулися й незалежні друковані видання.
Відома "Газета Виборча"
виникла ще на тлі підйому руху "Солідарність".
Її статті викликають невдоволення нинішнього уряду.
Як наслідок - "Газету Виборчу" намагаються позбавити фінансування.
Ярослав Курскі востаннє перевіряє новий випуск,
в якому йдеться про повноваження спецслужб.
Газеті дали зрозуміти, чим загрожує критика.
Нам відмовляють у рекламі.
В нас проблеми з розповсюдженням, тому що газета
більше не продається у державних аеропортах
і на державних заправках. І держустанови відмовилися від підписок.
Видавничий концерн хотіли розділити -
щоб газета, інтернет-сайт та відео-канал
не могли працювати під одним брендом.
Однак план провалився, оскільки такі структури
є і в консервативних ЗМІ. Проте від ідеї
скоротити іноземну частку власності до 15 відсотків - поки не відмовились.
Новий канал, де працює Беата Тадла,
пропонує глядачам суміш політики, місцевих новин і розваг.
Разом з нею сюди прийшли й інші колеги з державного телеканалу.
Шкода, що так вийшло. Однак теперішніх співробітників TVP
я навіть не можу назвати журналістами.
Журналіст повинен змальовувати події й розповідати,
що насправді відбувається.
А там тепер є тільки лінія партії.
Не всім звільненим колегам Беати  пощастило
знайти нову роботу за фахом.
Багатьом довелося змінити професію.
Польська журналістика переживає не найкращі часи.